hey guys this is vadim with max tech and
welcome to my ultimate gaming review of the m1
macbook pro now if you're wondering why
i'm calling this the ultimate gaming review
well that's because i'm going all out on
the games as you can see right here i have
a bunch of games loaded up and i'm going to
be playing games using four different methods
the first one is playing native arm games for
mac the second method is playing the older x86
mac games using rosetta 2. the third way is
playing ios and ipad games using side loading
and i'm going to show you guys how to do that
and finally the fourth way is playing windows
games using crossover now i don't know if
you guys remember this but way back in july
i made a video titled apple silicon is bringing
AAA gaming to the mac now when i made that video
i meant that after a year or two we would
finally have aaa gaming maybe even next year
with the expected m1x chip that i made a video
about definitely check out that video because
that's going to give you much more graphics
performance but i did not mean the very first
apple silicon max are going to bring aaa gaming
but to everyone's surprise after only about three
weeks people are already playing aaa games on this
machine in fact a whole community has been created
on reddit mac gaming of people playing aaa games
on the m1 max and a little bit later in this video
i'm going to be playing diablo 3 i'm going to
play cs go i'm going to play even witcher 3
on this m1 macbook pro so as you guys can see
i have an xbox controller for controller games
and i have an mx master mouse to play those aaa
games so let's go ahead and see if i was right or
i was wrong all right the first thing i'm going to
show you is multi-craft it's one of the few games
that's actually been updated for apple silicon
and it's running natively so one of the other
games is world of warcraft but i don't really want
to play that i don't play that and it's a massive
massive download by the way do not buy a 256 gig
model of one of these m1 max especially if you're
trying to game because you really can't load up
that much games we have a 512 gig model right here
it also has 16 gigs of memory but in reality
for gaming you only need the 8 gig model because
if you guys watched our intel xps versus m1
macbook pro video you'll know that apple's unified
memory is extremely efficient so 8 gigs on the m1
is pretty similar to 16 gigs on older intel max
but anyway here we are in multicraft it's
basically a minecraft clone it's running
natively for apple silicon and as you guys can
see it's running perfectly smooth like perfect
60fps our cameras by the way are set to 4k60 and
there you go i'm using my mx master mouse and
honestly i don't play minecraft i don't care
for it but here you go playing perfectly smooth
this game is extremely efficient we're
running with 10 cpu usage 43 on the gpu
the chip is at 42 degrees celsius it's incredibly
cool and as you can see the fan is off as well so
these apple silicon games are gonna run very well
of course this is a low end game we're going to
get into the higher end games in just a second now
i want to get out of this game and i want to move
on to showing you guys some iphone and ipad games
now the way you do that is you go to the app store
you search for a game and you have this
little section right here iphone and ipad
apps and boom there you go i'm going to show you
guys dark raider it's just a simple low end rpg
game let's open it up now what's cool
is that you can hit the full screen mode
bam obviously it doesn't cover the entire
display because ipads have a more square-ish
aspect ratio but as you can see i have my
controller right here the xbox controller
and it's working perfectly fine the fans are
still not running so it's really awesome to
see controller support working on the mac it's
only been three weeks since we've got our hands
on these so this is really really exciting now i
want to show you guys some of the apps that i side
loaded and to do that i downloaded imazing so
this is a paid app but you can get a two week
trial as you can see boom continue trial now what
you do is you connect your ipad or your iphone
and after you do that you go to manage apps it's
going to have you log into your icloud account
and then you can see all of your apps now what you
do is you right click on something and you click
download to library you can see it downloading
right over here there you go it just finished you
right click on it you click export ipa and i'm
going to throw it into the applications folder
go to applications find that game double click on
it it's installing boom there you go open it up
and it's playing battlelands royale we just
installed it just like that that's how easy it is
for a game like this this is not optimal because
this does not support controllers and that really
really really sucks but i am going to show you
guys some controller games here in a second
oh definitely not a good experience like this
let's go ahead and close that and let's choose
a better game here's an rpg game grim valor that
has controller support as you can see by the way
guys thanks for helping us finally reach 500k
subs we appreciate each and every one of you
so here you guys can see i
mean this is pretty awesome
controller supports working very well this
is kind of like a side scroller style rpg
oh that's fun now i want to show you guys
some more simple games some more popular games
for example clash royale works perfectly as you
can see it's this small little window but i can
go full screen and for this game you just use the
track pad just like that you can just battle it
logs you in using game center which is great and
i'm about to play with the real opponent apple
did an excellent job with this automatic touch
translation feature this is this is awesome so
if you want to play simple games like this i mean
you can no issues at all playing a game like this
anyway i showed you guys clash royale let's do
another one let's see just like that it's running
you know what let's try multiple king of thieves
let's open that up right here multiple games
running at the same time this is kind of funny all
right look at that you just switch over you switch
your mouse over and it works so easily i mean i'm
so impressed brawl stars let's open that up too
put it over here why not brawl holla let's do
that one too right over here playing clash of
clans look at that what about this let's find
a match here why not there you go oh boom all
right i got that how about let's play brawl stars
there you go searching for players logged in how
about this game look this game supports controller
support online play free for all let's go look at
this actually let's let's go full screen on this
hey it looks like it canceled out the audio from
the other games even though they're playing in the
background dude i don't want this oh you see that
get out of here bro this is pretty fun i've
gotta admit all right anyway let's exit out
of that there you go we have our games running
look at that cpu using what 39 23 44 the fan
is completely off chilling at 45 degrees celsius
playing all of these four games at the same time
just like that you exit out of them i mean this
is this is great let's spice it up a little bit
playing a fps shooter game with controller support
let's go ahead and full screen it there you go i
mean this works so well this is actually a pretty
decent game and it's running perfectly whoa bro
grunts i'm impressed how well this works on
this macbook pro and you get a nice big display
full screen mode now i did download
call of duty mobile but unfortunately
as you're going to see in just a second i
don't think controller support is working
just yet wait a minute it's working
controller support is working no way
it's working on call of duty mobile
all right let's do this oh my goodness
there you go and just like
that everything's working
don't play with your main account
if you're gonna try this out
because you can very easily get banned
i don't know why they would ban you but
triple q nice there you guys go look the fan
is still off i just played call of duty mobile
no issues 42 degrees celsius now let's finally
move on to the third method of gaming which is old
intel x86 mac games let's start out with
league of legends there you go we have the
league of legends client open let's go
ahead and hit play and do a blind pick
summoner's rift now what's very interesting is
that i just have the client open we're sitting at
99 gpu usage all right we're in game i'm gonna
go ahead and max out the resolution 2560 by 1600
that's native and let's go ahead and just max
everything out all right we got about 89 fps 79
fps i don't know if you guys can see that up there
the fps ticker 88 is that yasuo okay that's yasuo
anyway i mean 70 fps right there 69 fps guys
i maxed out the graphics completely maxed
out graphics i mean this is awesome this is great
league of legends running perfectly under rosetta
you don't even have to wait for it to get updated
i mean come on oh no i died again 72 fps right
there 74 fps right there 81 so obviously this runs
incredibly well it doesn't even need to be updated
no issues at all playing league of legends sorry
guys my team but i gotta move on by the way i just
finished league of legends the fan is still
off no sweat for league so here i am in steam
for the mac i'm about to play cs go under
rosetta here we are in cs go the lobby is
running perfectly let's play some arms race
here we are so far playing perfectly smooth
no issues at all come on man i don't know
why we have bots in here of course this
is a pretty simple and easy game but the
truth is that a lot of people play cs go
and a lot of people play league of legends they're
very popular games and right here on the m1 max
no issues at all playing perfectly smooth before
you couldn't do this with the base model macbook
pro taking a look at the settings we're at 1680 by
1050 resolution not bad just because i'm curious
let's do native it seems like the fps counter is
not working but here we are playing at native res
and we are no longer playing at 60 fps maybe
40 fps is what we're getting right now it's
definitely not as smooth as it was before this
might be playable i'd probably turn it down a bit
which i will here in a second how about i don't
know 1650 by 1050 again that was that was pretty
decent back at the lower res and i mean look at
this everyone runs faster with a knife got him
gotcha gotcha and this is not even native
performance under rosetta who would have
thought huh who would have thought anyway that
cs go let's go ahead and look at our temps
back to the finder we're at 92 degrees celsius
on the cpu we're at around 1500 rpm on the fan
not too bad i mean the fan really wasn't
blowing it was basically at idle now let's
get into the next game diablo 3 running under
rosetta and this is definitely a triple a
game here we are in the menus everything's
working very smooth and let's get back
into the game before i show you the crazy
performance check out these graphics options
native resolution 2560 by 1600 we're capped to 60
fps shadows are on medium textures on high physics
high clutter high anti-aliasing full screen there
you go there are the settings you guys seen this
look how smooth that is i mean i'm not noticing
any issues this is native resolution under rosetta
oh get out of here conjurer of death dude you're
screwed bro that was easy you could not do this
with a 13-inch macbook in the past never imagine
what's gonna happen next year when the m1x inch
comes out with potentially double the graphics
performance with this running this well on the m1
i am blown away i am not noticing any stuttering
any dropped frames in this game now with that i
want to move on to the most exciting way to play
games the fourth way this is using crossover
to play windows games now this is a paid app but
you get a free 14-day trial of the full version
so let's move on with this trial now to play
games like this all you do is you click install a
windows application you type in steam you install
steam and then after that you install two more
things you install directx for modern games you
click that and you do it within the steam bottle
make sure to do that right after that you find
dx vk and you install that also within the steam
bottle and then after you have those installed
you're going to click over here on the bottles
you're going to go down to steam you right
click on it go to settings and then enable
just like i did dxvk back end for d3 direct
11. once you enable that you're good to go
let's start steam and as you guys can see right
here we have the windows version of steam running
so if we look through my library when you click on
games that are meant for windows you can actually
install them now not all of them are going to
play a couple of games that i tried didn't work
but here i have some games that are gonna work as
you guys can see i have team fortress 2 installed
i have the witcher 3 which we're going to test
in just a minute because it's totally insane
and finally i installed a classic one of my most
favorite games from my childhood final fantasy
10 bringing back that nostalgia let's see if it
runs so here we have the launcher i never played
x2 because i thought it was kind of weird i play
final fantasy 10 so here i have the resolution i
try to add a bunch of different ones for some
reason it doesn't run at higher resolutions
it's kind of weird but i have the settings set
right here quality on low unfortunately that's
the only way i got it to run let's test it out
all right here we are guys final fantasy 10. i
had to mess with the settings to get it to run
here we are in full screen you can hear this
nostalgic music and for some reason the fps that
the steam counter is showing us is really bad
7 fps but it's working let's test this out do
i use space well oh can i get it can i get it
boom there we go look at that 18 fps so it's not
the best quality for some reason the resolution
isn't that great in this game but we are playing
this right here is probably the worst part of the
game oh it's horrible absolutely horrible part of
the game i mean hey it's playable we're playing
not the best fps not super smooth now since the
fps we're getting is not that great let's go ahead
and test out a different game within crossover all
right that was weird it just crashed and restarted
i'm not sure why that happened i just closed
down final fantasy so there is definitely more
optimizations to be done within crossover and with
the whole gaming and emulating in general but it
restarted pretty quickly there alright we're back
into steam and now let's try out team fortress 2.
here in the lobby it says we're getting over 100
fps we'll see how that changes as we actually
start playing all right here we are and it feels
decently smooth so far 52 37 fps just dropped 31
so you don't get that good of performance it seems
like in crossover so far 54 75 that's a little
better but i am having some weird drop frames
every now and then yeah this is a little bit weird
well i was able to kill that guy definitely
drop frames going on looks like we're i mean
we just hit 100 fps doesn't make sense we are
dropping down quite low every now and then
get out of here bro there you go 31 fps
definitely drops not a very good gaming experience
what's up bro it seems like when i'm not fighting
someone it's decent but as soon as i see someone
gets really bad really quick so there you go we're
playing tft the graphics quality isn't that good
either we're sitting at 1440 by 900 resolution and
the quality's a lot of it is set to low so i don't
know what's going on it's probably because it's
not that modern of a game it's using directx 9.
all right witcher 3 right here this is definitely
a aaa title let's run it using crossover let's
see the performance that we get here we are
which are three unfortunately the fps counter
is not working but we're gonna go ahead and
continue all right here we are in witcher 3 guys
look at that this is definitely much more smooth
i am getting some frame drops decent performance
playing witcher 3 this is a aaa title we're
playing this with decent performance using
crossover yeah that's impressive so it
seems like when you're using crossover
the more modern games like this run much much
better than games like final fantasy and team
fortress 2 that are very very old games guys
i was running that at native resolution 2560
by 1600 i turned off and turned down a bunch
of the other settings but native resolution
playing that let's turn it down a
little bit to see if we get better
performance let's do 1650 by 1050. all right
there you go i think it's definitely more smooth
definitely feels more smooth who would have
thought that apple's very first apple silicon
mac the m1 ship would be able to play games like
witcher 3. all right let's test out the uh battle
performance with these creepy dudes oh crap these
guys are strong unfortunately i don't know how to
play this game am i gonna die here oh yeah i'm
so dead anyway i mean it was performing well
we're not really getting any stuttering we're not
getting any performance issues playing witcher
3 just because i'm curious i'm going to check
out the performance we're at 92 degrees celsius
4 000 rpms on the fans there you go if i get close
i can definitely hear them that's what it took 100
gpu load 35 cpu load to get it hot playing witcher
3 after playing all of those games the iphone
games the ipad games call of duty mobile using
the controller really nice controller support
playing under rosetta league of legends perfectly
smooth diablo 3 perfectly smooth cs go decent
performance even crossover playing old nostalgia
games like final fantasy playing witcher 3 with
really impressive performance i have to say that
apple silicon the m1 chip is the best thing that
has happened to the mac in terms of gaming this
is a gaming revolution it's only been three
weeks we're already seeing developers updating
their games for native apple silicon support
and without that we're getting really good
performance under rosetta which nobody was
expecting this is shocking that a laptop like this
the 13-inch is getting good performance like this
in gaming so to answer the original question is
the m1 macbook pro good for gaming i have to say
yes this is performance on par with the best
16 inch macbook pro and when we see next year's
m1x chip that is just going to be on a whole
nother level and it's going to take gaming on
the mac to a higher level is just going to be
so impressive and even this is super impressive
and the last thing i want to mention is that it's
only been three weeks and developers are already
working on getting native support developers are
working to get crossover updated to support more
games rosetta's being upgraded as well so with all
that said i have to say that i couldn't be happier
with the m1 macbook pro for gaming so hopefully
you guys enjoyed this ultimate gaming review
and if you did go ahead and click the circle
above to subscribe because we're trying to reach
650k subscribers before the end of march so
please help us with that definitely check out
a couple of those videos right over there thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the next video